what is explanation oh well that's a  that's a really good question and  presumably we'll get into it this  afternoon I take it explanation is a  procedure for reducing cognitive itch is  curiosity  okay explanation unless it's entitled we  could treat explanation as a a class of  exchanges inquiries and answers to  inquiries that satisfy inquiry where  explanation turns out to be whether  something is an explanation now it turns  out to be contingent on the human  cognitive interests and limitations or  we can treat explanation as the full and  complete a causal account of explanation  or manner in which case it might not be  cognitively accessible to us  you